is it true that uh the the 50s stepped
up and paid your taxes like in my first
this is my second time having to go
through this but in the first time I
dealt with it he did uh he did help me I
he didn't actually 50 never paid nothing
that I didn't have to pay back so even
though he might have yeah he did help I
still had to give him that money back so
what he did do I didn't half and when I
did start the half he made sure he got
his back so so the but that's still
helpful that's still very helpful cuz if
it wasn't for him I wouldn't I wouldn't
have know what to do right you know like
I said I didn't have a lot of knowledge
of this [__] so once I made a few
dollars my first time having to deal
with bankruptcy was like okay I mean I'm
I'm a full-fledged celebrity my mother
still lived down the street in the
projects she's got to a point where she
didn't want to leave but now you got the
whole neighborhood dropping music off on
the porch and stuff like that I'm all
over TV so once I made a few dollars bro
my living circumstances was so crazy and
of course I might have added on a little
bit more extra but the first thing I did
was you know bought my mom's a
house bought myself a house and and and
and I bought everything I was supposed
to and I shouldn't bought you dig yeah
so here it is come the end of the year
I'm def broke and relying on other money
coming in that to to get me back
together and then all of a sudden they
hit me with this taxt thing that was
like what is this right so I didn't have
I didn't have knowledge of even what
it's the first time I ever filed texes
in my life and even then I didn't follow
him myself you know what I'm saying it
was his business accounting my it was a
conflict in interest in the beginning my
business account was his business
account right that umbrella that
umbrella that I W walked into started to
be realizing that it was it was a
different problem my my my lawyer at the
time was hired through his lawyer right
you understand so all of us you know
what I mean so a lot of those things
that it wasn't like nobody sitting down
and telling me you know what was going
on of course you know uh I did make the
decisions but you know I looked at it as
if
like this is my opportunity of a
lifetime and I know what I could do and
would do and did do with the opportunity
you know so that was more my focus more
than the business now looking back on
things if I was to do anything over it
was I would I would have I would have
had more knowledge and and took more
time in starting to learn the business
like I've had no choice to now you I
mean you were still pretty young during
the the whole gunit days right like
early 20 early 20s yeah early early 20
uh I came in in in uh into gunit in 2002
2003 I'm 42 now so you can y'all can do
the math out there right now so out of
all out of all the beef that you
inherited would you say like the IRS are
the biggest gangsters of them
all I will say they ain't to be [__]
with you know and uh you know like I say
man my experien is uh just just going
through stuff like that I've I've I've
you know how your mom says this old
saying uh a hardhead make a soft ass you
know hard head definitely does it's like
a lot of things that I I did do I I I
knew I shouldn't have been doing but
instead I I had a hard head and did it
anyway probably kind of like your crazy
ass too at that time you know what I'm
saying but yeah man it was just one of
those things where um had to learn the
hard way man for real for real in the IR
is one of the best teachers you can have
yeah cuz there's nothing you can do
about it there's nothing you can do
about it and that was one of I
experienced some of the most heart
heartful hurting things that stuck to my
life in regards of dealing with uh
bankruptcy and stuff like that my first
time after you know going through all
those things I end up falling out with
50 during my first bankruptcy and he
pulled everything away from me and I
couldn't make no money nowhere so I end
up getting resulted into uh all my stuff
being auctioned off so I woke up one
morning and and I'm in this mansion and
living my life and then I got the IRS at
my door The Raid with the and they're
coming in and taking all my kids stuff
and and and all of those different
things and and in that and in that
process uh I had a tour manager at the
time had left a weapon in my home you
understand he left they waited eight
months they waited eight months bro to
indict me on that on the weapon that I
never knew that was there never touched
no fingerprints but the fact that the
house was in my name it sent me to
federal prison you know and Federal
Federal Prison man so what was your
first Char in my life uh I did like 18
months over there with dealing with that
with that I went to yazu yazu uh Federal
Penitentiary I started my first time
going to the penitentiary was the low uh
and U you know that was a real
experience for me the low you mean low
security low security was my first I end
up going back you know but I I couldn't
understand uh you know I I mean I know
numerous people that it's caught
numerous gun charges but for some reason
the da at that time was
so you know adamant about uh sending me
to prison and stuff like that bro like
he was under the 50 umbrella
[Laughter]
I don't know I'm just kidding but yeah
man like at the they you know they found
a weapon in the house I I didn't have no
knowledge of it they found a a bullet I
used to have security and stuff like
that at my crib and stuff they found one
bullet that didn't even match the gun
that they found and charged me with a
fing in possession of a fire uh uh
ammunition do do you think the reason
they went so hard on you is cuz I feel
like back then the da really wanted to
like make rappers an example yeah uh
like when they [__] up the da where cuz
that's uh it was in here it was in
Tennessee the The Da the da actually
that prosecuted me in that situation the
first time was one of the hard well he
has a very very uh hard reputation or in
in throughout my city for actually you
know not playing and really Prosecuting
individual so you know I had no
knowledge of who he was until I started
to deal with that case in itself and uh
you know honestly he he kind of almost
scared me
into to to to to playing out you know I
didn't know what he would do he you know
he was one of those Das and I don't know
if he still is a DA or what but he's one
of those da is like you know
uh he's going to get a conviction one
way or another if he's on your if he's
on your ass type of thing so it was like
I had a lot of individuals that I had
encountered with whether it was just
meeting not knowing what they got going
on speaking what up what up and he might
have seen me on a picture where they
watching these individuals and thinking
that I'm involved with these folks but
it's like man I'm a celebrity I meet a
lot of people but I don't know what the
hell they got going on and uh he took it
as if like yes you do so his whole thing
was about questioning me about you know
certain things dealing with certain
individuals that I couldn't provide no
no answers I didn't even choose to sit
down to talk to you why am I even going
to talk to you about something that I
don't know and once once he seen that I
I wouldn't cooperate in in in his method
of doing whatever he was trying to do he
told me straight up or told my attorney
you know what I'm saying that he was
going he was going to send me to prison
and he did and I think I got caught up
as well in the middle of uh a lot of the
politics in my city because uh at that
time you
know uh my attorney is now the head of
the
da now so I think a lot of politics and
stuff came in in regards to I'm a big
fish in a small pond so that prosecution
of me was like I don't know maybe and
this is just me Wishful thanking I think
it was like I'll give you him if you
give me this type of thing like I don't
know man but hey I I got past that went
through that sentence got out it was
eight months for the gun no 18 months 18
months for the gun in federal prison
yeah what's the difference between
federal prison and state prison like is
there a difference in I don't know I
hope I don't find out I'm actually
fighting a situation now to State you
know what I'm saying and and I'm totally
innocent in that situation like I say
[Music]
um see what I'm saying they coming out
like what's going on bro
like what are they
doing well we are in the hood yeah but
see ain't that crazy though for me to
say that and
then but no honestly like um he's like
you guys wear a wire
yeah but uh yeah man I got out from
completing that 18mth Cent Man and uh
from there I uh I started I made a
decision at while I was in prison to to
actually go back to
gun you know in in my mind I felt like
cuz I I was away from gun when I went to
prison at that time like I say that
played a part of me going to prison
because 50 pulled out I didn't have
nothing you know what I'm saying so it
was one of those things that once I I
was in prison I'm and it's not like I I
I went to prison and was in no uh PC
protective custody or none of that I'm
actually walking the yard with you know
the guys that got 15 20 years been there
20 30 years and all of this everything
that comes along with prison I I
experienced it I didn't experience it
from an end of uh uh you know being
celebrity yeah I'm I'm a celebrity and
individual saying yo can you sign it's
for my kids you know what I'm saying
stuff like that so um my prison
experience was was was was real you know
I I had a chance to meet a lot of great
dudes that was from all over the world
and that's one of the biggest
differences I would say within the state
and the federal is that you know you
meet all these different people from
everywhere and the state is kind of
mostly locally wherever you from and uh
they'll move you around wherever you
might be
in Mississippi for a
year California the next year you know
it just depends you know what I'm saying
exactly you know how they choose to move
you around and did that time got out do
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce fre your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and sto's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude yes